في تطوير مستمر لرخائن ونمطي حياه يناسب
تطلعات المملكه وساكنيها مشروع جديد في
السعوديه يضمن مستوى البنيه التحتيه
المثاليه
وبعنصورها الاهم الطرق او تجربه من نوعها
في البلاد لتبريد الاسفلت باستخدام تقنيه
جديده قوامها مواد محليه الصنع
وللمساله ابعد من الابتكار بالتعامل مع
تحديات الحياه في مناخ صحراويا حار
بردوا هذه التجربه يعود الى امتصاص الطرق
لاشعه الشمس نحن في احد ايام الصيف ذروه
درجات الحراره تنعكس على الطرق التي تمتص
حتى 70 درجه مئويه ولو كانت هذه الطرق
المعتاده لا اطلقت ما تخزنها من حراره كما
هو الحال دائما في ساعات الليل
لكن التكنولوجيا الجديده تعدنا بليال
صيفيه اكثر اعتدالا خاصه مع اقتران الخطوه
باخرى تقتضي طلاء المباني السكنيه
والتجاريه بمواد محدده تخفف من امتصاصها
لاشعه الشمس ونتحدث عن استهلاك اقل الطاقه
وخفض لتلوث الهواء المكسبان الاهم في اطار
سلسله مبادرات حكوميه لتحسين نوعيه الحياه
والضمانات تجلت بعد اختبارها في موقعين
رئيسيين في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض لكن
التنفيذ الفعلي سيبدا من محطات الحافلات
والمترو الطرق السكنيه ومناطق المشاه سكان
السعوديه موعودون بالمزيد خاصه مع افتتاح
الهيئه العامه للطرق مؤخرا مختبرا مركزيا
يجري دراسات لتحسين تجربه مستخدم الطرق